Has political correctness prevented us
from having an honest conversation about
Islamic immigration in Europe?
Well, yeah, it's not only prevented us,
it's basically handicapped us um on a
number of topics, amongst which is the
one you just mentioned about Islamic
immigration in Europe. And um I think
there's just this idea amongst people
and it's been promulgated by you know
the powers of be the media the
politicians academics which is that
Islam and Muslims are like any other
religion and there's some truth to that
of course because Muslims are humans so
yeah I get that part but Islam because
of all this political correctness has
been so whitewashed its actual doctrines
its actual history especially visav
non-Muslims even more so visavv western
peoples like uh Christians especially um
if you're familiar with their history
and we can talk a little bit about it or
their doctrines it'll all make sense
that you know what you're seeing in
Europe when you bring in Muslim mass
Muslim migration um and you see what you
see which is criminality and sort of
ghettoization and the things that are
happening in the UK and England uh
grooming of women and you know rape sky
skyrocketing in Sweden and all sorts
thing and even lesser things that people
aren't aware of that I follow like
desecration of churches constantly
happening in European nations and often
times you find it's Muslims who are
responsible all of this actually has a
long history and it's not just a long
history but it actually has a it's it
has a doctrinal foundation okay so what
about the claim that we constantly hear
excuse me that
uh Muslims and Christians lived in peace
in harmony for centuries. Is that not
correct? No. That's a big fat lie. And
I'll I'll actually give you a nice quote
from a well-known prestigious professor,
John Espazito of Georgetown University
where where I went for a time when he
was a teacher there, but he has it
written in a book. and he basically says
five centuries of peace between Muslims
and Christians elapsed before a
political papal power play led to a
series of so-called holy wars that have
left a mis a legacy of misenduring and
mistrust from Muslims towards Europeans.
So what he's basically saying with that
quote is that before the first crusade
which was called for in the year 1095
um and from the beginning of Islam which
the first year of Islam is 622. So from
622 to 10995, the supposed five
centuries, he's saying there was nothing
but peace. And that is absolute bunk
because what happened in those
centuries, just the first century
actually, from 632 to 732, Islam
actually violently conquered 3/4 of what
was once Christian territory. People
forget that all of the Middle East and
North Africa, from greater Syria, which
encompasses modern-day Israel, Jordan,
Lebanon, etc. to Egypt all the way west
to Morocco. Not only was that Christian,
that was more Christian than Europe.
That was where Christianity was, this is
why Constantine moved the capital from
Rome to the east to to what? New Rome,
Constantinople. Um, so in that one
century through violent force, Muslims
conquered and and annexed all that
Christian territory and then they went
and conquered Spain in 7-Eleven. And
then I give you that one century 632 to
7:32 because in 732 you have the battle
of Tours. You have Muslims in the middle
of France committing horrific abuses and
atrocities and burning churches and
raping women and enslaving people. Okay?
And so my point is and yet you have
professors telling you that before the
first crusade everything was fine.
Muslims did nothing wrong in one year
alone in 109 one khif one Egyptian
fatimid khif destroyed 30,000 churches.
I mean wrap your mind around that.
30,000 churches which first of all that
underscores how Christian Egypt and
Syria was like I was saying but also it
just shows you the sorts of persecution
that was going on and which is what led
to the first crusade. That's what they
they don't want you to think that
something that Muslims did something to
provoke the first crusade. Okay. So we
have two things going on here. We have
doctrine right going on and maybe you
could talk about Islamic doctrine. Sure.
And that doctrine is interpreted
differently you know in the stands which
means land you know manistan what have
you that that's a very different kind of
Islam than the world's largest
population was Indonesia right or Sunni
Shiaist so we have we have doctrinal
issues and then we have historical
issues right so can can you unpack the
historical issues first sure before we
go on to the doctrinal issues yeah so
the historical issues I sort of already
touched on with the first century. But
basically um you know one of the ways I
like to explain Islam is it's basically
the genius of Muhammad is that he took
the pervading tribalism of his society
7th century Arabia and he deified it.
Okay so what is tribalism? Tribalism is
us versus them, right? You and me and my
family and my brothers and then my
cousins versus that that group, right?
That's pure tribalism. And that's how
basically tribal peoples and pastoral
types of people have always lived. They
fight and kill and pray on the other.
All right? To be outside of the tribe is
the enemy. So what Muhammad did is he
really turned he took that concept, but
now it was no longer about blood or race
or people. It was about who's a Muslim,
who's part of our group. Okay, the word
who's part of Islam, who's who's a
follower of Allah and the prophet. And
so, and then and this is why if you
actually look in the sources as I have
and I've kind of spelled it out in some
of my books, the earliest Muslim
converts, whether they were Arabs or the
Turks or the Tatars, meaning Mongols or
the Berbers, the thing that highlighted
their whole existence was just jihad.
Because what they did is they continued
raiding on the others, but now the other
was anyone and everyone who's not a
Muslim. And then on top of it, not only
did they were they doing what they
always did, but now they were considered
holy warriors and they're they're God's
beloved and they go to heaven and they
get martyed and they get the 72 virgins,
etc., etc. So, it actually it really
it's an incentivization. It amplified
tribalism. Okay. And um so anyway,
that's a that's a sort of like backdrop
of of the appeal of Islam from the very
start and why also a lot of different um
tribal peoples embraced it
wholeheartedly. It's the same thing with
the Turks. So I was talking about um you
know the first century, the Arabs.
Before long, the Arabs waned and then
the Turks became the new standardbearers
of Islam. Basically the the the new
jihadists essentially. And it's the same
thing with them. You know, you look at
their earliest oral epic. It's called
Deadi Corut. And you read about their
exploits and it's all about and they all
they do is they boast. I burned the
church. I beheaded the priest. I took
many slave girls. I don't mean to laugh.
No. I'm sorry. No, no, but wait, it gets
better. And I, you know, I took many
slave girls and then, you know, and then
I worshiped Allah. So, like the whole
point is he contin The Turks continued
doing what they were doing, but now it
had a pious veneer, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Now it had like a uh a religious element
to it which now they're they're the good
guys for doing all that. Yeah. Okay. So
I I want to talk so let's talk about
doctrines and then I'm going to push
back on a few things. So it you
know tell me about Islamic doctrine.
Tell me about the tax. Yeah. Yeah. Uh
yeah. All right. So basically, look, a
lot of people get lost in all these
rabbit holes trying to talk about
Islamic doctrines and and they f and you
know, they they find teachings and they
say it's bad and they criticize it. I
don't care about all that. I'm only
interested in those doctrines that
affect me as a non-Muslim. For example,
a lot of people will criticize Muslims
for, I don't know, polygamy, for
draconian laws, cutting off hands, for I
don't care. That's their society. If
that's how they want to live, that's
fine. So what I like to identify is the
the laws that actually affect me as a
non-Muslim, right? And they really come
down to the first and they're actually
interconnected. They're three in a way.
The first one in Arabic it has a name.
It's
called okay and you can translate it as
loyalty and enmity or more simply love
and hate. Okay. And this is in the Quran
and it's basically goes back to the
tribalism. It tells Muslims they have to
hate everyone who's not a Muslim. The
Bible the Quran itself says and that
that is in the Quran that's in the Quran
and it says even if it's your father and
your son and your children and your wife
etc etc. I once translated an Egyptian
cleric uh he was asked a question. He
was he was offering a fatwa and they
said you know because Islam allows
Muslim men to marry Christian women and
Jewish women and he basically he was
saying yeah you can but because she is
an infidel you have to hate her. So you
can have sex with her and you can
whatever please profit from her money he
said but as long as you have to keep the
hatred in your heart for her and you
have to show her that you hate her. So,
but but what what about the claim that
oh this these are just a bunch of uh a
few fringe lunatics and a fatwa is just
a legal verdict and it's not a it's
extra Quran it's in the Quran what I
just what I'm telling you I mean yeah
okay that is a fatwa but the fatwa is
very much based on on a verse in the
Quran that says you have to hate
non-Muslims okay so you know yeah I mean
there can be any legal quibbling about
it but that verse is there and it's a
well-known doctrine and it's what really
is the most divisive thing and which
creates that sort of tribalism. So,
first of all, there's hatred and it and
the teachings are such. So, there's a
verse that says this, you know, you can
um you know, you can like cooperate with
an infidel or even be their friend as
long as you're doing it out of tea. And
tea is a word which means fear and
dissembling. And anyway, that has led to
another doctrine which means you can
befriend the non-Muslim, you can act
like you're their friend, you can do
everything, but you have to have in your
heart hatred for him. And uh so if
you're in a weak position and you can't
show the hate or live the hate, you
know, fine. If it's dangerous for you,
if you're living around infidels in
let's say Budapest, then you have to
internalize the hate, but it has to be
there. Okay? So these are actually this
is a Quranic doctrine doctrinal
principle. It's not some celi or Wahhabi
madeup thing or ISIS or al-Qaeda. It's
there. The only problem is those guys
champion it whereas other Muslims n they
don't want to talk about it. Maybe they
don't follow it personally, which makes
I get that. Would they be like, have you
heard the the phrase cafeteria Catholic?
It's like you just are they cafeteria
Muslims? They just kind of pick and
choose. You have that, too. But see, to
me, you know, the you the word moderate
Muslim is just inaccurate. It's kind of
an oxymoron. I don't think that exists.
What you do have is secular Muslims and
cultural Muslims and cafeteria Muslims.
Yeah. But there's no moderate Muslim. To
me, that's something of an oxymoron.
Okay. What What about like Ann Arbor,
Michigan? That's filled with M there's a
very high Muslim population there and
they're not blowing up. Yeah. Okay.
Because it comes down to you asked me
about doctrines. I'm telling you the
doctrines. That doesn't necessarily mean
Muslims are following it or or it could
be that they're waiting and they're
biting their time. I'm I I always
differentiate between doctrines and
people. Same thing with Christianity and
Judaism. I can clearly talk about
doctrines within all religions but at
the same time that doesn't mean that
doesn't equate every polyore doing it
right. Okay. So back to Islamic
immigration. Uh well wait let me finish
the sorry. So the first one is the
hatred and then the second thing is the
hatred manifests itself obviously into
what is called jihad right and jihad is
warfare against the infidel in order to
subjugate and kill or bring them bring
them to you know the light of Islam or
whatever. Jihad isn't just uh okay we go
to warfare with the with the non-Muslim.
The hatred's there. So it's already you
already have so much incentive because
as a little child you've been taught to
hate the non-Muslim. So, is there a
hierarchy of hate? Uh, yes and no. Um, I
would say no starting because when it
comes down to the Quranic teaching, the
non-Muslim is the uh is the enemy who's
to be hated. Now, I have to give you
some Arabic terminology which is much
richer. So, the Arabic word that is
habitually used in the Quran and in
Islamic scriptures is for the for the
what we say infidel is kaffer. And that
word has so many negative connotations.
Uh you know like it so it's unfortunate
because in English Quran translations.
Yeah. When that word is is there they
just translate it as unbeliever or
non-Muslim which sounds very neutral to
a western ear but it's actually so
loaded with you know I mean to say that
even jokingly uh I remember I was
amongst Muslims and I said something
like oh yeah I'm a keer and they were
just like they just recoiled. That's
such a horrific thing to say, but that
is how every non-Muslim is described as
a keer. Um, and but then you know some
people play this game and they tell you
that Christians and Jews are the people
of the book because there are in fact in
the Quran they're described they're
they're described as scriptuaries the
people of the book and so Christians and
Jews are still to be hated because
they're non-Muslims and they're still to
be fought in the jihad. And now we come
to what you were asking about which was
the tax and the discrimination. The Jiza
they have to be fought until they either
convert or they embrace living as
secondclass citizens and pay tribute
which is like it's basically extortion
money. It's called Jiza and that's
founded on Quran 9:29. Um so basically
the hierarchy is now how does that
translate practically into the real
world? It it translates into you know
okay we hate Israel more than anyone
because of what's happening. So, so this
Okay. Yeah. I was saying like what you
know based on whatever the circumstances
is then that infidel becomes the one
that's especially hated. So the the and
correct me if I'm wrong, it's last my la
at my my last look it was either 11 or
13 countries, Muslim countries, the
punishment for apostasy is death, right?
Um yeah, I'm not sure the number, but I
can tell you that is the Islamic
prescription. That is what Muhammad said
in what's considered a canonical hadith,
which to most Sunni Muslims, uh who make
up 90% of the Muslim world is basically
equivalent to the Quran. It's uh and he
said whoever leaves Islam kill
him. But within Islam there's other
teachings. It's you know like and this
is where it gets a little nuanced. So
some of the there's four schools of
Islamic teaching. They're called medbs.
And some of them embrace the killing.
Others say well first you give him a
chance, second you put him in a room and
starve him. Third you beat him. And then
fourth you kill him. You know so that's
that's the nuance. So what what we saw
happen in
Syria very
recently when they they went around
killing the Christians and Alawites and
the media the legacy media portrayed
that is uh Assad sympathizers. Yeah.
Turns out that was simply not true.
Yeah. It was just they were just going
after Christians. Absolutely. and and
that what you just described has
happened countless times in in the
modern era where uh you know Muslims
kill Christians and the media dissembles
in so many different ways and I've
actually cover I have a whole book that
I talk about how they dissemble um and
it's uh you know I'll give you one
example when 21 Coptic Christians were
beheaded in Libya in 2015 that yeah yeah
remember that that was like that got
some media attention but it got it got
like onetenth the media attention of
what was what happened at the same time
which was a gorilla that got killed in a
zoo. I forget his name Han Pri or
whatever. Um so it just gives you an
idea you know 21 people who rather than
renounce their faith were beheaded got
onetenth the actual coverage of a
gorilla getting killed. Okay. So I feel
you're the type of guy I don't have to
say I don't have to give a trigger
warning or say to be offended. But I'm
I'm going to ask you some questions now.
All right. Just be careful because we're
on a bridge.
So, so we started talking about Muslims,
Muslim immigration in Western Europe,
the failure to have an honest
conversation about that. And I don't
mean that that's universal, but it's
largely cultural. I mean, some people
like Matt Goodwin are talking about it.
The reform parties bring it up. Some
people are talking about it. cultural
commentators like Carl Benjamin or um so
we're not being we're we're not speaking
honestly Eric Kaufman has some really
interesting things about uh
um crime rates who contribute to the
treasury incarceration rates right so
why do you think we're not speaking
honestly about the problem uh because
well one of the reasons is oh and I'm
sorry I'm sorry and Jews fleeing I meant
to say that too right yeah I think one
of the reasons is look and and this has
to do with sort of western what's been
going on in western peoples. I think
this idea one of the one of the biggest
taboos and one of the things that
everyone's terrified of that answers
this question is western people which is
to say white people by and large have
been so um brought up to be in terror of
the word racist. Okay, they're so scared
that someone will think they're racist
or call them a racist that they've just
and and Muslims tend to be an exotic
religion. they're mostly brown or black.
So if you say anything against them,
boom, you're a racist. So I think that
is one of the reasons that has really
silenced people. This is why in England,
they'd rather give up their daughters to
get raped rather than report the truth
because they're scared of being racist.
Okay. Um and I think and and the police
catch them because they're scared of
being racist. Exactly. Okay. So that's
definitely one of them and and closely
aligned with this idea is also I think a
sort of um you know there's this
anti-Christian mood that's been in the
West ever since the 60s, let's say. So
there's a sort of sympathy towards any
religion other than Christianity. In
this case, it would be Islam. Okay?
Let's go back to the first reason. Okay?
And this is why I gave you that kind of
semi-trigger warning. Okay? So, it's
it's hard to to state this exactly
without sounding like a total
but don't don't they deserve it? Who's
they? Well, don't do don't the cultures
that let this happen to themselves Oh.
deserve because isn't that just kind of
you're saying like the countries that
let this happen to themselves deserve
it? Well, yeah. I mean, if they're
democracies. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
uh I am I'm actually not unsympathetic
to that position because I felt the same
way. I know there's a you know, I most
of what I write about and I research is
the historical Islamic assault on
Western civilization in Europe. And
those people, the forebears of today's
Western descendants, fought tooth and
nail to protect their people and their
culture and their religion. And you're
letting millions of Now their
descendants are are are doing exact
opposite and they're suffering
accordingly. So, but they should they
they you so in a democracy, you have to
be held responsible and accountable for
your policy decisions and so but a lot
of people have nobody to blame but
themselves. Yeah. Exact. I know. But
then a lot of people will tell you like
so if you go and speak to a regular
person in England or in the UK a lot of
them I think would agree with us. All
right. But they're but their political
leaders are on the opposite side and
okay but they vote. Okay. But it comes
back same thing. I know you're right.
You're right. I agree. But then some
then they'll tell you well it was it's
they've stolen the election. You've
heard that one before, right? And I hear
that also in Europe. So I don't really
know. Isn't it the West's fault? Yeah,
it is fundamentally the West's fault
because this is so different than what
happened historically. Historically, it
was the same dynamic. Muslim invad
Muslims invading European and Christian
territory, but they fought back tooth
and nail. Now you have you have to also
remember historically, you know, the the
West was the was the underdog. Islam was
the super behemoth power, especially the
Ottoman Empire. This was a monstrous
powerful organization, empire, etc. And
the west was also always the weak dog
and they fought tooth and nail and they
got slaughtered and they were always
outnumbered etc etc. I discuss a lot of
it in my book defenders of the west. Um
but now you fast forward to today and
the west is so much more powerful than
the Islamic world economically
militarily in every way possible
culturally technologically and yet
they're being terrorized by Muslims.
Why? Because it is they themselves who
are doing this. They've opened their
doors. They've shut down all debate.
people like me, if I say what I'm
saying, even though it's grounded in
truth and history and doctrine, I'm shut
down. I'm a hater. I'm an Islamophobe.
And so all that what happens is, you
know, Muslims being so weak inherently
compared to the West today, even though
they're small and outnumbered, they can
get away with so much violence and
terrorism and what you see happening in
Western Europe. Okay. So, let let me ask
you a question.
Do you think that the West should
surrender to Islam?
I mean it seems like it already has to a
certain extent. Uh I don't but if they
cut a deal
now if you look at the well first of all
if you look at the statistics of how
many people come into the UK alone last
week I read a statistics 2,000 people in
a week they can't stop illegal
immigration and so yeah they can they
just don't want to. Okay. Okay. So okay
so we'll agree with that. Okay. So they
don't want to stop uh illegal
immigration. Forget about legal
immigration. uh and we know that certain
elements of the population are having
not just more children but more children
at younger ages and we know the
incarceration rates we know we we know
the data so can you construct an
argument for me oh well first before
that do you think that the west should
surrender to Islam well I think it is
let's just speak about demographics
because that's sort of where you're
going and you know according to Pew
studies something like in by 2050 uh
Germany is supposed to be something like
50% Muslim okay and the UK So, isn't it
better if they surrender now? I mean,
that's what they're doing. It's a I've
actually like a formal surrender. I've
never under Let me Let's just say this.
Have you ever seen a civilization or
society, let's say white people? I know
it's politically incorrect. Okay, you
white Europeans. They make up something
like 3% of the world's population. Yeah.
And yet the expected and
complying to everyone and suppressing
their culture, their religion, their way
of life to accommodate everyone, though
they're only 3%. I mean, I often I often
say jokingly, but maybe it's not a joke,
like I'd like to see reservation parks
for white people, you know, because
they're on their way to extinction,
really. Um, and it's all selfdone. It's
amazing. Nothing like this has ever
happened historically where a group of
people go out of their way to kill
themselves. Okay. Well, some someone can
make the argument that they deserve it,
but but they deserve it if they're doing
it to themselves. Yeah. I mean, you want
to kill yourself. People who want to
commit suicide, I don't fight with them.
You want to kill yourself, it's all
right. Go ahead. Yeah. Gad Sad calls it
suicidal empathy. Okay. So, what do you
think about the idea that the West
should surrender to Islam and cut
themselves a good deal now before it's
too late?
Are you I mean, are you being facitious
or are you serious? Well, I mean, what
do you think about it?
I think I've written about this because
if you're going to surrender, if you're
going to surrender like you're saying,
that means I would do that if it's
absolutely too late and you have no way
out. And that's sort of what you're
implying. I think there is still a way
out. What would that be? Uh grow some
balls. But we that you know that by the
way, you know, that's not going to
happen. Uh and no, it could happen. I
mean it's still there's pockets of sort
of I don't want to say resistance but
there's and a lot of this actually
really goes back to the complete and
total emasculation of man mostly western
men and really this is the root source
of it all that you know you have men in
Europe who can't even protect their
women folk from invaders like I said in
England because they don't want to be c
because they don't want to be called
names okay racist or something like that
so yeah I mean if it gets down to it
where they have no choice and you better
cut a deal you think they have a choice
Now, I think they still have a choice.
Will they do it? I don't know. I think
it's going to get worse before it can
get better. And I think the people, a
lot of the regular people in Europe,
empathize and agree with what I'm
saying, but their leaders don't. So,
really, their biggest problem, European
people, is not Muslims. It's their own
leaders. That's where it all starts and
that's the source of it. Okay. I'd like
to invite someone on the show who
disagrees with you. Who should I invite
for another perspective? Oh, I'm sure
there's a lot of guys like that. Um, I
don't usually consort with them. I find
them despicable. So, I'm not a good
person to ask, but let me think. I can
get back to you. I mean, they're they're
actually a dime a dozen. You're talking
about Muslim apologists. Well, I'm
talking about some but someone who has
to have some credentials, you know, like
like you you've written books. You're a
fellow at a think tank. You have
scholastic. Someone who would say what?
That the West needs more Muslim
migration. Muslim Islam. Yeah. Islam
migration isn't a problem. I'd like to
university. Go to any university. the
Islamic Studies Department and any of
those guys will tell you that. Okay. Uh
if people want to find your work, where
can they where can they find you? Uh
well, my website raymond Ibrahim.com has
a lot of things. I've also started a
YouTube channel, so go and follow me
there. And um also my book, Sword and
Scimitar and Defenders of the West
really cover a lot of what I've
discussed with you. They are bestselling
books. Yeah, I'm grateful for that. Um,
so yeah, my website and uh my YouTube
channel, which is my name, the Holy War
channel it's called. Excellent. Thank
you for taking the time, Raymond.
Appreciate you.